>> Sean: WELCOME BACK TO
"HANNITY."
WITH REACTION TO MY OPENING
MONOLOGUE, ROD ROSENSTEIN'S
TESTIMONY ON CAPITOL HILL AND
THE CORRUPTION WITHIN MUELLER
SPECIAL COUNSEL AND AUTHOR OF
THE BOOK TRUMPED UP.
HARVARD LAW SCHOOL PROFESSOR
ALAN DERSHOWITZ IS BACK WITH US.
YOUR REACTION TO THE HEARING AND
TO THESE EMAIL EXCHANGE.
THE DEPTH IN TERMS OF THIS ONE
GUY STRZOK.
THAT HAPPENS INTO ALMOST
EVERYTHING WE HAVE DISCUSSED FOR
A YEAR.
DOES THE FBI NOT HAVE ANY OTHER
IT'S A PROBLEM NOT ONLY OF
PERCEPTION OF BIAS BUT THE
REALITY OF BIAS HERE.
ANY DEFENDANT WHO GETS INDICTED
BY THE MUELLER GROUP WILL BE
ABLE TO CHALLENGE THEIR
INDICTMENT IN COURT.
MUELLER WILL SAY, LOOK, OUR
STATUTES PROHIBIT ME FROM
CONSIDERING POLITICAL
AFFILIATION.
I JUST HIRED THE BEST PEOPLE.
THEY ARE ALL DEMOCRATS WHO
SUPPORTED CLINTON.
BUT BIAS WITHIN A POLITICAL
AFFILIATION.
THESE FOLKS WHO WROTE THESE
EMAILS SHOULD HAVE RESCUED
THEMSELVES.
THEY HAVE A STRONG BIAS JUST
LIKE RUTH BADER GINSBERG HAS A
STRONG BIAS AGAINST PRESIDENT
TRUMP AND I HOPE SHE WILL RECUSE
HERSELF IN ANY CASE INVOLVING
THE PRESIDENT.
NO, BECAUSE I DON'T SEE EVIDENCE
OF CRIMES.
DO A COMPLETE EVALUATION OF THE
STAFF.
>> Sean: ISN'T THAT PATHETIC
THAT HE NEEDS THIS.
YOU KNOW WISEMAN HE DOESN'T
BELONG ON THAT TEAM.
YOU ARGUED BEFORE THE SUPREME
IT'S A VERY GOOD QUESTION.
ANDREW HAS A REPUTATION OF BEING
AN EXCELLENT AND VERY TOUGH,
ZEALOUS LAWYER.
I DIDN'T KNOW ANYTHING ABOUT HIS
POLITICAL AFFILIATION.
I HAD A CASE AGAINST HIM NOT SO
LONG AGO.
HE IS VERY, VERY GOOD.
HE NEVER SHOULD HAVE SENT THAT
EMAIL CONGRATULATING SALLY
YATES.
>> [OVERLAPPING TALKING]
>> Sean: HOW ABOUT WITHHOLDING
EVIDENCE?
IN OTHER CASES USING BEYOND
AGGRESSIVE TACTICS.
>> I AGREE WITH YOU.
AS A CIVIL LIBERTIES LAWYER, I
AM APPALLED WHEN THEY WITHHOLD
EVIDENCE DEMOCRATS OR
REPUBLICANS.
BIAS.
>> Sean: THIS ONE PARTICULAR
TEXT MESSAGE.
THERE ARE OWN 10,000.
MCCABE.
I HAVE NOT CONFIRMED THAT.
THERE IS NO WAY TRUMP GETS
ELECTED IF WE FOLLOW THAT PATH.
IT'S LIKE AN INSURANCE POLICY IN
THE UNLIKELY EVENT YOU DIE
BEFORE YOU ARE 40.
THAT'S CHILLING TO ME.
INVESTIGATIONS.
WE SHOULD START WITH ETHICES
I SUGGESTED A NON-PARTISAN
COMMISSION LIKE THE 9-11
COMMISSION.
WHEN YOU START WITH A SPECIAL
COUNSEL YOU ARE IMMEDIATELY
I THINK THAT'S WRONG ON BOTH
SIDES.
I AM OPPOSED TO THE REPUBLICAN'S
CALL FOR A SPECIAL COUNSEL.
GET THE CRIMINALIZATION OUT OF
OUR SYSTEM AND JUST LOOK TO
LEARN THE TRUTH.
WE HAVE TO FIND OUT EVERYTHING
WE CAN ABOUT ANY BIAS IN THE
MUELLER PROBE OR IT WILL BE
SUBJECT TO CHALLENGE BY ANY
CRIMMIAL DEFENDANT INDICTED.
>> Sean: PEOPLE WANT TO HAVE FUN
ON TWITTER.
>> I CHALLENGED HIM TO A DEBATE.
HE SAID MAYBE IN MAY.
LET'S HAVE A DEBATE NOW.
>> Sean: I WILL GIVE YOU TWO
SEATS ON MY SET.
IT WILL BE AN OPEN DEBATE AND I